this is a production of cornell
university
um
i want to just say the three
uh the four key items i want you to walk
away with we'll talk about them again
but
the first point is methane and nitrous
oxide are the most important emission
sources on farms these gases have a high
global warming potential we'll talk
about that more soon and then also when
you evaluate a change in practice you
need to think about your baseline and
you need to count all three greenhouse
gases that's carbon dioxide methane and
nitrous oxide together
to ensure that you're accounting for net
greenhouse gas emissions
not all strategies are equal we need to
choose real permanent and verifiable
opportunities
to ensure meaningful reduction in total
long-term greenhouse gas levels
and we believe we can meet our 2030
mitigation goals in new york state this
is a broad overview and
we will talk about all of these points
as we go forward
so the outline of the talk what are the
sources of ag emissions i'll do a united
states ag inventory and i'll also do
some estimates that i made for the
northeast united states
we'll talk about what is a global
warming potential
and why agriculture must focus on
methane and nitrous oxide and then we'll
go into a new york case study both
looking at some new york state specific
inventories and also the new york state
um
unprecedented mitigation climate
mitigation mandate then we're going to
look at
how to evaluate different farm
greenhouse gas reduction practices the
importance of the terms real permanent
and net greenhouse gas accounting the
importance and issues around
miserability and verifiability and we're
going to introduce our smart decision
matrix to help policy makers and farmers
and landowners alike evaluate what
strategies work best for them
and then we're going to feature our top
five mitigation strategies
what are the sources of agricultural
greenhouse gas emissions we're going to
start looking at just the united states
and then i'll do something on the
northeast usa
so
what i'm going to present first for the
u.s is from the 2021 u.s epa greenhouse
gas inventory you can find it at this
link below
and this is just the emissions from the
agricultural sector in the bar chart in
the pie chart in
the
sort of orange red color you'll see that
agriculture contributes 10
of total
u.s emissions you'll also notice that
energy
accounts for almost all of our emissions
problems as a country
now if we look at this 9.6 or 10 percent
of the u.s total emissions
we for agriculture
we look at the bar chart and
specifically you can see that
agricultural soil management accounts
for
345
million metric tons of co2 equivalents
enteric fermentation and manure
management are also very large and these
are smaller categories which we're not
going to talk about today
why what i want to point out is that
this agricultural soil management
has nothing
is primarily from nitrous oxide
emissions so when you think about
agricultural soil management most people
think about carbon but actually what we
need to think about is the emission of
nitrous oxide from our soils nationally
livestock
enteric fermentation which means the the
burping or farting to be frank of
livestock animals and manure management
emit large amounts of methane and you'll
see that this is the second largest
source
sources
second and third
and the
others are all carbon dioxide
uh emissions key point number one
methane and nitrous oxide are the two
most important emission sources on a
farm
moving on to the northeast usa the data
you're going to see next is from a
publicly available state inventory tool
that anybody can access
and it has default values
that can sometimes be problematic but we
ran the state inventory tool
for the northeast climate hub region
and you'll see the same categories the
ag soil nitrous oxide the manure nitrous
oxide
manure methane emissions the livestock
enteric emissions and the total
emissions
and then you will see the percentage of
total emissions as nitrous oxide methane
and carbon dioxide
now if we point out if we pull out
delaware you'll see that delaware really
needs to think about nitrous oxide and
if you pull out vermont in contrast
vermont needs to think about methane in
terms of
priorities as a state
so
the take home message here is that low
livestock states such as delaware need
to focus on nitrous oxide or their
nitrogen use and nitrogen use efficiency
whereas high labs livestock states such
as vermont
pennsylvania and new york need to focus
on methane
that comes from livestock enteric
emissions and manure management
to note energy is not counted in energy
use on farm is not counted
by the agricultural sector it is counted
by the energy sector it is still
applicable to farms but it is small
relative to these methane and nitrous
oxide emissions
so
the same logic that happens for states
also happens for a farm so if you are
primarily a crop farmer
your best opportunity is to reduce your
nitrous oxide emissions by improving
your nitrogen use
if you're a livestock farmer you should
really focus on the entire commissions
resulting from your feed management
strategies and your manure management
strategies
so a summary of the sources of emissions
while most of climate change is caused
by very large amounts of fossil fuel
combusted
adding very large amounts of co2 to the
atmosphere
most sectors of society need to reduce
co2 emissions from fossil fuels
agriculture however needs to focus on
reducing its methane and nitrous oxide
emissions
now i want to make a point here it's not
that agriculture produces such huge
amounts of methane quantitatively large
huge large amounts of methane or nitrous
oxide it's that methane and nitrous
oxide are very potent greenhouse gases
so what do i mean by that
we're now going to switch into the
potency of these different greenhouse
gases with a focus on carbon dioxide
methane and nitrous oxide the common
gases in agriculture
there of course many other greenhouse
gases that we do not need to consider
but organ like sectors like industry do
need to consider
so different greenhouse gases have
different abilities to cause climate
change
there are two dominant effector factors
that affect how potent a greenhouse gas
is
the first is how long does it live in
the atmosphere what is its lifespan once
it gets up there
and the second is how effective is it in
trapping the heat
this is where we introduce the term or
phrase global warming potential often
referred to as the gwp
to account for these differences between
greenhouse gases
scientists have created a factor called
the global global warming potential or
gwp
technically the global warming potential
is a measure of the total energy that a
gas absorbs over a given period of time
usually 100 years
relative to the emission
of one ton of carbon dioxide
after you apply this factor to these
differently potent gases
the common unit is called the carbon
dioxide equivalence
often referred to as co2e or sometimes
co2e cube
so
this is a chart of these global warming
potential factors
you can see the greenhouse gases on the
left
carbon dioxide is always one and you can
see methane and nitrous oxide
on the left
and the most common global warming
potential factors are over here on the
right they refer to a 100 year time
frame meaning they consider
the potency over 100 years they come
from the intergovernmental panel on
climate change ipcc
uh assessment report number four which
was published in 2007
and in this scenario in this
edition of the ipcc report methane is 25
times as potent of a greenhouse gas than
co2 and nitrous oxide is 298
times as potent as carbon dioxide
all of the inventories up to this point
have used these gwp values
what i want to find out in special for
new york
is that in the
new york state 2019 uh climate
leadership and community protection act
which was signed in 2019 it is a mandate
that says that we will use the gwp 20
minus feedback values you don't need to
know all those details but the point is
you will see that methane is now
considered 84 times as potent and
nitrous oxide is 264 times as potent
other states will have to decide what
they want to do i'm just making a point
here that the inventory that i'm some of
the information i'm about to show you is
going to
refer to this this
basically the real changes in nothing
so key point number two
methane and nitrous oxide are potent
greenhouse gases so very small changes
in these emission sources multiply
quickly resulting in a large impact on
the emissions inventory from agriculture
i'm going to now talk about a recent new
york state inventory which used
uses the traditional global warming
potential and the new york state climate
mitigation
i mandates know why it's breaking this
up
so
this is new york state's inventory that
was published in 2019 you will see that
it's referring to gases that were
emitted in 2016 right reports always lag
the data that it came from
and you will see
that the total emissions in new york
state were 206 million metric tons of
co2 equivalents of which
four percent came from agriculture
okay so right now we should all just
realize again agriculture is a small
source of our total emissions right and
all of us need to think about our energy
consumption because almost all of these
other
numbers are coming from energy sources
energy source emissions
so how much does this mean that new york
state according to this report emitted
around 8.3 million metric tons of co2
equivalents that's what four percent is
okay so that's just to give you a frame
of reference in the old context of the
old global warming potential that new
york state no longer uses
i want to just segue right now and talk
briefly about the clcpa or this climate
leadership and community protection act
um that was signed into law in 2019
it is about regulating greenhouse gas
emissions it is unprecedented and it
applies to all sectors so while today
we're going to focus on just agriculture
it's not just agriculture new york city
apartments have to get
their emissions down the transportation
sector has to get their emissions down
the industry sector has to get their
emissions down we all have to get our
emissions down so what are these goals
they are large by 2030 new york state
all sectors need to have a 40 reduction
in greenhouse gases
by 2050 we have to have an 85 percent
reduction in greenhouse gases and be net
neutral
in 2020 peter woodberry and i i were
hired by new york state to create a
greenhouse gas inventory for new york
state agriculture
now what we're
we're this is all still in process and
we're using um the 2019 refinement
for our methods we're using the 2019
refinement of the 2006 ipcc guidelines
for national greenhouse gas inventories
that was adopted in 2019
these are preliminary results for 2019.
you'll note that i say that this is
in-sector emissions
we estimate that new york state
agriculture emits about 21 million
metric tons of co2 equivalents
you will see very quickly that the
largest source of emission
is from
our dairy cows 13.4 million metric tons
next is around 6 million metric tons
from manure management and then field
nitrogen emissions are around 2 million
metric tons
this so the in sector meaning the
agriculture only sector is 21.3 million
metric tons
we have also made some estimates for
out-of-sector emissions such as energy
use from
tractors and things like that
for total emissions
of 23.2
but again
uh this is all boundary for
this is all about discussing boundaries
for what is in and what is out of a
sector
and we're just going to focus on
agriculture only emissions and not think
about energy for now
so if you remember
on a previous slide it's actually 8.3
million metric tons
was from the previous new york estimate
and you'll see that we now are
estimating 21.3 million metric tons
this quote-unquote doubling of emissions
in our recent estimate that we have been
doing is a function of the new york
state mandate to use this 20-year global
warming potential it's not that we have
that many more dairy cows since 2016
it's that we have changed the way that
we're doing our accounting and we have
chosen to use a 20-year global warming
potential
all right now we're going to switch
gears you know what the problem is i've
listed the problem we've got 21 million
metric tons to get rid of
how do we do that and how do we do it
meaningfully so that we reduce extreme
weather conditions for future farmers
and
future citizens
i wanted to step back and talk about
some key terms
these terms sound very simple
real permanent measurable and verifiable
but they are super important
and yeah they're just going to seem very
obvious but actually when when we're
thinking about biological systems it's
quite difficult to assure yourself that
you're making real permanent measurable
and verifiable greenhouse gas mitigation
real
well
it is quite simply the quantified
greenhouse gas reduction must represent
actual emission reduction seems obvious
okay
some questions
did you count your net greenhouse gases
so that is did you count your carbon
sequestration
from your soil health practice plus any
nitrous oxide emission
or any tractor pass emission peter
woodberry is going to give you a whole
hour on this so hold your horses on that
did you gather a baseline before you
implemented the practice to ensure that
your change in practice actually made a
difference to the greenhouse gases
did you sample sufficiently did you
sample spatially enough did you sample
frequently enough
to ensure that your new practice has
made net gains
did you gain the system by taking away
stuff from one area and putting it into
another area
there's a lot of components to what
actually makes a real mitigation
strategy but the point is we as a
society need to focus on real mitigation
because it quantitatively reduces our
total emissions
it is real reduction to stop climate
change and it's a simple concept and a
very difficult one to implement
permanent
climate change's problem is a problem of
hundreds to thousands of years is a
mitigation practice permanent or
reversible and on what time scale is it
permanent or reversible so let's just
talk about an unimportant
uh scenario you got a bottle of soda
maybe there's a pennsylvania company
that seals carbon dioxide as the bubbles
in your can of soda
me the new yorker opens that bottle of
soda and releases that co2 that is
temporary and reversible carbon
sequestration and storage
pensa does pennsylvania get to count a
reduction on its emissions inventory and
does new york state count an emission
i'm trying to point out some
complexities here about accounting in
general about greenhouse gases first
what is the boundary of accounting are
we counting just pennsylvania are we
counting just new york or are we
counting the united states are we
counting the world
what is the permanence of this carbon
sequestration
if that soda
was um
never opened and put in a landfill and
never crushed in the landfill maybe we
could call that permanent carbon
sequestration
that that carbon dioxide bubble
but if i open it up six months later
that is not permanent carbon
sequestration and that is not going to
get us to the goal
of reducing total greenhouse gases in
the atmosphere that is causing climate
change
and so this is what i mean by the time
scale of permanence
so let's talk about carbon sequestration
because
it is talked widely about as being one
of the best natural climate solutions
for the world there are many kinds of
carbon sequestration
so carbon sequestration literally means
removing carbon from the atmosphere
through biological or physical means
so
we all know photosynthesis can add
carbon to soils to plants to food it can
add carbon to
forests mechanically we can remove
timber from a forest and we can add that
carbon to build our houses and then
those houses live for hundreds of years
or we can compress carbon dioxide that
comes out of a smoke stack and store it
store it in an old oil well
or
we can keep fossil fuels in the ground
by harvesting biomass for bioenergy and
just surface cycling carbon
or using other renewables like wind
solar and geothermal these are all very
different strategies on what carbon
sequestration means
but we all must recognize that carbon is
the most delightful currency of life i
just had an apple this morning and it
was fantastic the carbon in that apple
was very short-lived
soil carbon
is one to thirty years four is carbon
can be one year if we combust it for
heat
that's not quite right or hundreds of
years if we put it in a beautiful piece
of furniture
or in a building
but fossil fuels that remain in the
ground represent millions of years of
carbon sequestration and so for every
amount of fossil fuel that we can keep
in the ground
that is an incredible kind of carbon
sequestration
my point only is that climate change is
a long game and we are not prepared to
think in
long game scenarios
and that carbon sequestration is only as
good as its permanence
soil carbon is a very important for soil
health but it provides modest greenhouse
gas benefit due to permanence and other
issues again peter woodbury will share
more on this in detail in the next hour
but for now i recommend that if you're
interested in long-term carbon
sequestration focus on ag woodland
management or a4 station of former ag
lands for permanent carbon sequestration
and of course figure out how not to use
fossil fuels
measurable
can the mitigation be sufficiently
detected and measured
can you gather a baseline how frequently
do you make your measurements do you do
it annual annually for soils do you
measure both the carbon and the nitrous
oxide emissions
do you do it decadally for trees do you
just do tree measures
measurements do you just visually look
at it the number of measurements to
track the change
do you use the same number of tests for
any project or do you change the number
of tests relative to the size of the
project
what is the location of the measurements
do you always choose the same sites each
time you go back or is it randomized
do you categorize different types of
fields or put
systems in different kinds of strata
how much effort does it take to measure
your greenhouse gas impact
and is that worth it
these are questions we have to think
about
verifiable
verifiable refers to the greenhouse gas
reduction that must result from
practices whose performance can be
readily and accurately
quantified
monitored and verified
so
as in measurement how appropriate are
the tests for valid accounting how
comprehensive how expensive how easy are
they to implement
and report
who does the verification do you hire a
third party verifier do they have
insurance do you have insurance
how rigorous is the verification
do you do direct sampling measuring
daily monthly annually
do you use a lookup table or are you
using a black box model again peter is
going to talk about the limitations and
opportunities for models in the next
hour
and finally
who is held accountable if
a sequestration fails
remember the goal our goal always
is to reduce our total ghg it's that
simple but it's actually quite difficult
to implement so key point number three
when evaluating a change in practice
a baseline must be set and all three
greenhouse gases must be counted
together to ensure that a change in
practice results in net greenhouse gas
reduction and that these greenhouse gas
reductions are permanent
or long lasting
again key point number four sorry all
practices should be real permanent and
verifiable to ensure society is
achieving climate stabilization like why
do it if you're just gonna make up
numbers right the whole point is we need
to get together and make sure that we're
doing rigorous work
so
the goal of our particular research is
to determine effective practices for
agriculture to mitigate greenhouse gas
emissions and that means we pay
attention to real permanent and
verifiable ghg reduction strategies
so i want to switch now to broad
categories
there are five broad categories in which
you can mitigate greenhouse gas
emissions on the farm you can sequester
carbon so you can sequester carbon in
trees soils long lived wood products
you can destroy or reduce methane so for
example you could capture the methane
from a manure storage and simply flare
it
you could increase your efficiency your
efficiency and what i mean by that is
your arm on farm energy efficiency you
get a more efficient tractor you uh
have improved nitrogen use efficiency
you
increase your milk production efficiency
so you feed your cattle less feed and
you need to
have fewer acres to produce that food
but you still produce the same amount of
milk
or you can displace fossil fuels you can
do that by producing renewable energy or
you can replace concrete and steel which
are extremely energy intensive building
materials you can replace those with
high quality wood products and there's a
whole kind of innovative
area to explore there
and finally and in my opinion most
importantly you can conserve
figure out ways to reduce how many
tractor passes or how energy efficient
your tractor is figure out ways to
reduce natural resources can you reduce
how much synthetic nitrogen you need to
put on that field
figure out ways that we society at large
can reduce food waste
and then of course leave forests as
forest right we need to leave our
working lands as working lands so they
can help us through this process
so these were sort of conceptual broad
categories now i'm going to get into
sort of
agricultural system
systems so in terms of dairy
some of the things to work on are feed
management which reduces methane and
nitrous oxide and
thinking about different ways of
managing your manure to reduce methane
and nitrous oxide
for crops we need to think about the
relationship between carbon and nitrogen
and their impact on co2 and nitrous
oxide emissions again peter's going to
give you a whole hour on that
woodlands
think about if you've got woodlands and
apparently in new york state 20 of
agricultural land is in woodland
if we can figure out how to improve
forest management on farms we can
increase the carbon sequestration and
value of those woodlands or you could
think about growing trees within current
agricultural production such as alley
cropping or civil pasture
think about our idle ants some say we
have up to four million acres of
underutilized or idle lands in new york
state and shrubscrub or various other
forms
we could think about
taking those idle lands and growing
trees on
them
called aforestation and sequester large
amounts of co2
we could put solar in wind energy on
those idle lands or we could activate
those idle lands for growing new biomass
for feed or fuel
and of course conserve all the ways to
reduce energy or research resource use
and conserve land
so
we now have ideas on what we can do how
do land managers and policy makers
accomplish
multiple goals how can we prioritize
greenhouse gas mitigation alongside all
the other things that we need to think
about as a society or as a farm manager
we have come up with something we call
the smart decision matrix
and it's in our 60 page carbon farming
report which you can read i'm just going
to give you a brief overview to it right
now
but smart refers to five key
characteristics that we evaluate for any
greenhouse gas mitigation practice
s stands for services or co-benefits m
stands for
is it a large or small measurable amount
of greenhouse gas mitigation that can be
achieved a refers to the cost to achieve
the greenhouse gas reduction does it
cost a lot to implement could you make
money if you implemented it could you
save money or are you going to need help
is it realistic to implement
do we have the resources and technology
available do we have to engage 20
million people or do we engage 500
people in order to implement it and the
time frame of implementation
so just to give you a little bit more in
depth of what i mean by services or
co-benefits
does the greenhouse gas mitigation
practice result in improved soil health
community relations adaptation to
climate change profitability
air quality water quality biodiversity
or renewable energy
does the greenhouse gas mitigation
strategy
result in a
large and measurable greenhouse gas
mitigation
for the state to
to
to encourage the state to come up with
policies to incentivize it and to what
degree
is that mitigation
verifiable
how achievable is it and
basically in this one we're just talking
about how much does it cost how much do
we think it's going to cost to
reduce a metric ton or in this case you
can see mega gram mega gram equals
metric ton i'm sorry for my changes in
in notation here
but
um this is all about the cost to
implement
realistic is
uh the number of acres that this
practice is applicable to the number of
stakeholders that need to be
engaged
what kind of technical tools do we need
and are are they already currently
available so can we do it now or do we
need more research and education and
technology before we can
and time frame
what is the lifespan of the
infrastructure we're building what are
the time limits of the mitigation
strategy
and the short and long term
effectiveness effectiveness of the
strategy
and really what we're saying guarantee
is
this is a measure of permanence
for affecting long-term mitigation
so in our report we evaluated 13
practices that you see here and now i'm
going to focus on
the top five mitigation practices
so our top five mitigation practices
came
with these
um
with within this um
with these key elements they cost less
than 75 dollars per metric ton
they represent real and permanent
mitigation most can be directly verified
they have a wonderful suite of
co-benefits and many increase
productivity and
efficiency of new york state agriculture
our top five based on our smart criteria
selection
were improved livestock feed management
which actually can save a farm
money
manure cavern flare
to
cover and capture methane and flare it
nitrogen use efficiency
which can also save a farm money
improved management of woodlands
which can increase profitability of a
farm on a long term
if those woodlands are
used for high value timber
and planting trees on idle lands which
is really giving a gift to future
generations
of of an amazing uh natural resource of
a new source of
forest biomass for all kinds of purposes
okay now i'm trying to pull everything
together
you'll remember that our estimate for
new york state ag emissions was 21.3
million metric tons this is the number
we have to reduce
with these mitigation with three of
these mitigation strategies feed
efficiency manure cover and flare and
end-use efficiency we can reduce around
six point let's just say seven million
metric tons of co2 equivalents
that effectively is 32 percent below
our 2019 emissions
if we add in a four station we haven't
done the calculation for farmwoodland
yet but if we add in a four station of
1.7 million acres of possibly 4 million
available in new york state
the feasible mitigation is 11.7 million
metric tons or
a 55 reduction from the 2019 emissions
now of course i have a caveat
the clcpa goals actually specify that
the 2030 goal is a 40 reduction below
1990 numbers
so in our inventory for new york state
we estimated that the 1990 emission is
15.3
so the clcpa goal of a 40 reduction is
40 below this 15.3
so that means our total emissions in
2030 needs to be about 9 million metric
tons and currently we're at 21.3
our top four
mitigation strategies that we feature
here right
get us to 37
that is we have a pathway to achieving
this really rigorous and ambitious 2030
greenhouse gas emission
mitigation goal
how do we do it well we already have
some existing programs in new york state
such as the climate resilient farming
cost share for cover and flare soil
health and water quality initiatives
new york state dec's
dec has the trees for tributaries
growing perennials or trees along our
waterways to protect our waterways and
also capture a small amount of carbon
we have an incredible education and
outreach network like many of you on the
call today plus again markets has a
bunch of education and worksheets that
can be deployed on farm
new york state also has the
environmental protection fund open space
program
there are conservation easements there
may be future programs such as the
regional greenhouse gas initiative
offering offsets
the regional greenhouse gas initiative
is the regulation of the electricity
sector and there's a possibility they
might be able to buy
offsets from the ag sector but it's
probably unlikely
there's also talk of carbon tax carbon
trading payment for ecosystem services
it's a new field everything is
burgeoning we don't know but there's
certainly going to be many new programs
so
we're talking ultimately about the value
of carbon what is it really worth
well i told you
that reggie is regulated um northeast
electric sector and they are
they buy allowances
in order to emit and right now
those allowances are selling for nine
dollars and 30 cents a short ton of co2
then there are voluntary markets which
are about 15
a ton
um
and then there's a social cost of carbon
which new york state estimates for 2021
is 123 a ton
and what the new york state social cost
of carbon is talking about is it's
saying
a ton of co2 emitted in 2021 will cause
123 dollars of damages to future
generations that is
maybe
there's flooding on the farm and you
lose crops or maybe there's flooding in
new york city and you lose buildings
right
this social cost of carbon is an
estimate of how our activities today can
affect
um the
the
costs of damages to future generations
and so i just want to show you this
range
of how carbon is currently valued again
it's a new field and we're all just
trying to get our head around it so it
makes sense that there's this large
range
but the point is all of us need to start
thinking about what is the value
all right
i'm going to skip this slide
i'm going to skip that so reality check
we're all in this together we have
serious goals we have limited time we
have limited money there are plenty of
good opportunities now let's choose
wisely let's be patient while we develop
new strategies with our growing
awareness and let's make sure we build
out new research so that we can get to
2050 as well as 2030.
so this is a summary of the top five
strategies for agriculture at least from
our perspective in new york state but
probably applicable to the northeast
and i just want to remind us all that
it's not just agriculture that's being
regulated
and that agriculture that all of us are
dependent on agriculture and our
behaviors also impact agriculture and so
just a quick slide on systems thinking
if we have one acre of land and we
uh put inputs right we have to buy
tractors we need to buy fertilizer right
all of that goes into this land and
maybe we produce crops maybe we produce
bio energy or maybe we decide to not do
that and put in new forests or maybe we
actually deforest this one acre or maybe
we increase our livestock production
regardless of what we decide to do with
this one acre of land
we have inputs
but then we have to process those
products and there are losses and
inefficiencies there
and then there are end users who use
these products efficiently or and
efficiently and then they end up being
recycled or in waste system streams with
other kinds of emissions there also
what if the processing and product
production was 24 20 more efficient
could we have 10 percent less land that
is engaged to produce this product or
what about you and me as the end user
what if we reduced 50
less of edible food waste what would
that do to the upstream emissions from
the agricultural system what i'm trying
to get at here is it's not just farmers
that need to think about
um
greenhouse gas emissions from farms we
as a society need to think about our
behaviors and how we have impacts on
groups such as farmers who are producing
these products
and finally
it's also not just farms for example i
have a 700 square foot apartment in new
york city it's a seven
seven
stories high so i have a very tiny
footprint
um for my house
but new york city apartment buildings
are being regulated and so my building
got a b minus on its energy grade which
we have to post on our on our front door
and that means in 2030 my building has
a three thousand dollar fine every year
but by 2035 my building has a 50 000
fine every year if we don't reduce our
greenhouse gas emissions from our
building and there's some pretty
innovative things that are happening
with building energy efficiency
another point here is that all the
reduced energy that new york city
buildings do have a direct impact on the
acres of state because if we need less
electricity to heat and run our
buildings in new york city we need less
acres that are used for solar panels
so in summary
new york ag has a path to 2030 and given
the gravity of the situation we must
ensure our money and effort are spent on
real permanent and verifiable
mitigation we also must ensure that
we're doing net greenhouse gas
accounting of all three greenhouse gases
together
we have to remember that farms are one
of the most sensitive industries to a
changing climate and what we do we do
for the future the sooner we start
reducing the less stress on society at
large
for 2050 we need more research we need
better data and we need to come up with
some kind of reporting
to achieve these 20 50 goals
it is incredibly hard to imagine 2050
we all have to start thinking creatively
imaginatively and differently about 2050
because
there is a lot of innovation and
conservation that needs to happen
again peter's going to feature the fast
ghg tool and he's going to highlight
some of the things that we've talked
about net accounting of carbon and
nitrogen from soil health practices
the concept of permanence and some
difficulties with verification i want to
say thank you all for attending
this work has been supported by many
programs but this webinar series in
particular is supported by smith lever
project
listed here
feel free to contact us or visit our
website
these are our key references
we are in search of extension agents
swcd
agents nrcs agents interested in
becoming regional leaders for greenhouse
gas mitigation please contact me
this is the first of our webinar series
to be held going forward please register
please fill out the brief and anonymous
poll and we will take questions
jenny there are some questions in the q
a are you able to see those or would you
like me to read them
i can see them
okay great
okay
um alex depilis at 10 29 says new york
new york's choice to use ar 520 or gwp
84
would seem to lead stronger actions to
reduce methane compared to the hundred
year why this choice and or what are the
tradeoffs for this choice
okay
and can you plug
okay
i have not figured out how you can plug
the 20-year gwp into the epa state
inventory tool but i'm sure that that
there are tools that are coming along
uh just because we're all having to do
this so that's question number two why
this choice
okay
let me just say it doesn't really the
priorities in new york state don't
change
between the two gwps
right methane is still the number one
issue in new york state with the 100 gwp
versus the 20-year gwp
so
the priorities at least in our state are
the same regardless of which one you do
the 20-year
gwp definitely highlights the reduction
in methane
lots of people are criticizing it i
personally am in favor of this because
we have to
we have to make real progress quickly
and
methane is a short-lived climate
pollutant
it affects ozone it affects all kinds of
things so it isn't just we're not just
addressing it as a climate change issue
we're addressing it for multiple factors
but also um
because it is short-lived if we can
quash it right now um then we are taking
a
a
very potent greenhouse gas out of
service and then we can focus on the
longer lift ones everybody has a
different opinion on it in a way it
doesn't really matter we have so much we
need to reduce um so that's my quick
answer or long answer to that do we want
to take a question from the room joseph
okay i'm not hearing you joseph so i
hope everything's okay i'm sorry we have
a question
so if
and um
so you just want to know more about the
process
um
a one minute explanation of the nitrous
oxide emission process from
soils a one-minute explanation of the
nitrous oxide emissions so
peter is going to talk about this in the
next hour but basically
um through biological processes
basically with microbes and in the soil
nitrous oxide comes out of the soil and
simply because nitrous oxide is 300
times as potent of a greenhouse gas
its value adds up quite quickly now this
nitrous oxide can come from synthetic
nitrogen it can come from a newer
nitrogen it can come from the blue
nitrogen
so it's not the type of nitrogen though
that can affect the dynamics in the soil
as you probably all well know
um but
the the main
point we we are trying to get across is
that
soil carbon sequestration has been
spoken about a lot and we feel it's very
important to recognize that alongside of
soil carbon sequestration we must
really pay attention to the nitrous
oxide emissions
did that answer your question
yeah that was great
okay any other questions from the room
no we're good
okay
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu